dbgap is a database of phenotypes and
genotypes this repository houses the
data produced in large scale usually
genomic based research studies dbgap has
an advanced search interface it's solar
faceted it allows you to actually delve
into the study details the variable
details and even see the distributions
and the values within the variables that
can all be made public before you
request access this way you can browse
the data and make sure that you want to
request access some of the variables
that we allow you to search for are
individual level phenotypic data and
potentially different types of molecular
data we designed a very simple but
highly effective submission scheme where
the data sets could be defined by the
submitter with the data dictionary that
describes each element within that data
set
we want to try to annotate those
variables that were collected
differently by different studies
to some control vocabularies and these
are largely found in the umls which is a
nlm product it's a metaphasaurus of
several different vocabularies and so
we've been working with a number of
groups one of the groups is actually
from Listerhill they've been mapping the
variables when appropriate to link terms
and so we can take in those annotations
and we can make that part of our search
interface we've worked with a number of
other groups to do this there's an nhgri
funded it's called Phoenix it's a
controlled set of measures but those can
also be tied back to variables in a
similar way to the umls vocabularies
another group based in Heidelberg
Germany called the medical data models
are mapping to umls kui terms and the
nhlbi funded top Med project with the
third party annotations we're able to
allow people to search across studies
and find variables Within These studies
that were previously more difficult to
find we're incorporating these
third-party annotations to include this
within our fire schema so the fire
schema is an API to query the phenotypic
and study metadata from the study and
embedded within the fire data structure
you can put the controlled terms as a
system
I want to get the word out there that
it's a free resource use dbgap to
augment your research